la suisse a imposé ce lundi une
quarantaine obligatoire de 10 jours à
toute personne venue du royaume uni et
d'afrique du sud depuis le 14 décembre
les chiffres ne sont pas bons dix mille
deux cas supplémentaires en 72 eur 201
décès et un taux de reproduction de 1,06
au moins pendant un mois les
établissements sportifs et les lieux
culturels resteront fermés les
restaurants peuvent ouvrir dans les
cantons dont le taux de reproduction du
virus est inférieur à 1 alors qu'ils
fermeront dès ce mardi dans le reste du
pays
certaines stations de ski peuvent rester
ouverte mais devront instauré les mêmes
mesures restrictives pour les magasins
et les lieux de restauration
la décision de fermer ou noah
appartiendra à chaque canton tous
désormais conscients de l'enjeu la
situation et l'évolution de la pandémie
ne correspond pas à nos attentes sont
les nouvelles infections sont en
augmentation en suisse dans la majorité
des cantons le taux de reproduction du
virus est supérieur à 1 il fait
attention au décalage c'est la situation
d'il ya quelques jours mais on voit
quand même que l est à un très haut
niveau et surtout la situation du
personnel soignant dans les hôpitaux
dans les centres de soins n'est pas
tenable
ainsi à long terme la suisse est devenu
samedi le premier pays d'europe
continentale a autorisé un vaccin contre
locaux vides 19 celui mise au point par
les laboratoires pfizer et biotech
si à partir de la semaine prochaine il
sera théoriquement possible de se faire
vacciner
il faudra probablement attendre début
2000 21